In a few minutes, all of you will march through
FitzRandolph Gate as newly minted graduates
of this University.
Before you do, it is my privilege to say a
few words to you about the path that lies ahead.
Though in my case, to say a few words without jumping off the platform during my speech.
It looks like fun actually, but I would not want to do that without a helmet.
Whether on the platform or beyond it.
It is indeed a privilege, and also a joy, to
address you, for all of you who graduate today
have accomplished something genuinely
important and worth celebrating.
You have completed a demanding course of study.
It will transform your life in many ways.
It will expand the range of vocations you
can pursue, increase your knowledge of the
world, deepen your capacity to appreciate
societies and cultures, and provide a foundation
for lifelong learning.
So we celebrate here on the lawn in front
of Nassau Hall, as do other college communities
in courtyards, auditoria, arenas, and stadia
around the country.
Graduates toss caps in the air
and professors applaud.
Families cheer and
holler enthusiastically.
Yet, even as we do so, we see a strange trend
from columnists, bloggers, think tanks, and
politicians.
In essays, books, and speeches, some of them
suggest that too many students are earning
college degrees.
Too many college graduates: that is a very
odd claim, because the economic evidence for
the value of a college degree
is overwhelming.
For example, in 2014, economists Jaison Abel
and Richard Deitz of the Federal Reserve Bank
of New York estimated the average annual return
on investment from a college degree, net of
tuition paid and lost earnings, at between
9 percent and 16 percent per year for a lifetime.
For the last two decades, the return on investment
has hovered at the high end of that range,
around 15 percent per year.
By comparison, the historical average return
on investments in the American stock market
is around 7 percent per year.
That is why my friend Morton Shapiro, the
president of Northwestern University and a
leading educational economist, says that for
most people, the decision to invest in a college
degree will be “the single best financial
decision they make in a lifetime,” even
if judged purely in terms of financial return
on investment.
A degree conveys many
other benefits as well.
For example, college graduates report higher
levels of happiness and job satisfaction,
even after controlling for income.
College graduates are
healthier than nongraduates.
They are more likely to exercise, more likely
to vote, and have higher levels of civic engagement.
To these pragmatic considerations we should
add the joys that come with an increased capacity
to appreciate culture, the arts, the world’s
diversity, and the inherent beauty of extraordinary
ideas.
The numbers I have quoted
are not specific to Princeton.
On the contrary, they are averages over all
four-year degrees, in all fields, from all
colleges in the United States.
Think about that for a moment: on average,
all degrees in all fields from all colleges
generate an annual return between 9 percent
and 16 percent, and this return is supplemented
by additional benefits to health, happiness,
and quality of life.
How could anyone think
we need fewer college graduates?
Some people answer that you can learn a trade
without getting a college degree.
Welders, they observe, can make more money
than many college graduates.
That’s true.
There are, of course, reasons why you might
want to get a college degree even if you plan
to become a welder.
You might worry, for example, about what happens
if technology renders your trade obsolete,
or arthritis leaves you unable to practice
it, or you want to move into management or
explore other interests.
A college degree equips you to respond to
the changes—to yourself, and to the world—that
inevitably occur over a lifetime.
Still, if pundits and politicians were saying
only that America needs better vocational
training, I could agree wholeheartedly.
It would be terrific if more people could
get the training they need to practice a trade.
But at the same time it would also be great
if more people, not fewer, could receive the
extraordinary benefits that come
with a college degree.
So I ask again: why would anyone think we
need fewer college graduates?
I think there is a simple answer.
Education requires
high-quality teaching.
Teaching, in turn, depends upon
skilled labor, which is expensive.
As a result, the up-front cost for education
is real, large, and easy to measure.
The returns are equally real and even larger,
but they accrue over a lifetime, are hard
to measure, and vary
from person to person.
It is tempting to wish that you could get
more certainty at lower cost.
The people who call for fewer degrees
yield to that temptation.
They emphasize the short term.
They focus almost entirely on the price of
college and on the salaries students might
earn in their first jobs.
That is a mistake.
A college education is
a long-term investment.
It enables graduates to develop and adapt,
and it pays off spectacularly in the long
run.
The idea that we would be better off with
fewer college graduates is a short-term swindle,
a swindle that will cheat America’s young
people, weaken the nation’s economy, and
undermine our future.
We need to have the confidence to invest in
our young people and to ensure that a college
education is accessible and affordable for
students from all backgrounds and financial
circumstances.
I hope that all of you who graduate today,
and who experience the power of education
in your own lives, will become advocates for
the value of higher education in our society.
There is a national conversation taking place
right now about the value of higher education,
and we need your voice
in that conversation.
We need you, in other words, to help others
to achieve in the future what you achieve
today.
How can you help more
students earn college degrees?
Here are three suggestions.
First, become advocates for the
importance of completion rates.
A college education produces a tremendous
return—if you get the degree.
Returns are much lower if you start college
but do not get the degree.
The highest default rates on student loans
do not involve college graduates with big
debts.
They instead involve students with small debts
who never finish college and so never get
the earnings boost that
comes with a degree.
A few moments ago, we awarded an honorary
degree to President Barbara Gitenstein.
Over her nearly two decades leading The College
of New Jersey, she raised the College’s
four-year graduation rate from 58 percent
to 75 percent, a number that puts TCNJ’s
on-time completion rate among the top 10
in the nation for public colleges and universities.
By raising TCNJ’s graduation rate, President
Gitenstein has improved the lives of thousands
of students who might have left
school with debt but no degree.
Be an advocate for higher education leaders
like Bobby Gitenstein, and for colleges like
TCNJ that commit to
improving completion rates.
Second, support America’s public
institutions of higher education.
State subsidies for public colleges and universities
have declined precipitously, and state funding
represents an increasingly small share of
the budget at public research universities.
At the University of Michigan, for example,
state funding now accounts for only about
9 percent of total revenues.
In the 1950s, by contrast,
that number was 80 percent.
Tuition at state universities has risen not
because they have increased their expenditures
per student, but because state legislatures
have hollowed out their other sources of support.
America depends on its
public colleges and universities.
They are engines of
social mobility and innovation.
Princeton and other private universities make
essential contributions to the nation and
the world—but there is no way that we could
ever replace America’s great public institutions.
They are a national treasure,
and I urge you to support them.
Third, stand up for the importance of enabling
more students from low-income families to
earn college degrees.
Princeton’s Great Class of 2018 graduates
today as the most socioeconomically diverse
class in the 272-year
history of this University.
You will not hold that record for long.
Other classes already at Princeton
will break your record.
Our graduate programs are likewise drawing
upon new sources of talent: this spring we
admitted the most socioeconomically diverse
class of doctoral students in Princeton University’s
history.
At Princeton we believe in socioeconomic diversity
because we know that to achieve excellence
as a University and as a nation we must draw
talent from every sector of society.
We know, too, that a Princeton degree is a
rocket-booster for students seeking socioeconomic
mobility.
If we want to heal the divisions that inequality
has produced in this country, we must ensure
that students from low-income backgrounds
receive the educations they need to develop
their abilities and contribute to our society.
As I look out at our extraordinary class of
undergraduate, master's, and doctoral degree
recipients, I take pride in your excellence
and your diversity, and I am excited about
the contributions you will
make in the years ahead.
The world needs more
college degrees, not fewer.
We need more celebrations like the one we
hold today, with more proud families and happy
graduates ready to go out and make
a positive difference in the world.
All of us on this platform are thrilled to
be a part of your celebration.
We applaud your achievements.
We send our best wishes as you begin the adventures
that lie ahead, and we look forward to welcoming
you back to this campus on future visits.
To the Great Class of 2018 and all of our
graduates, congratulations!